Un jour en EPS, il m'a marché dessus et ne s'est pas excusé.
Alors, furieuse, je l'ai attrapé et je l'ai poussé par terre.
J'avais pris des cours de judo.
(Rires)
Notre bagarre n'a pas duré deux minutes,
mais elle symbolisait cette furie
qui montait en moi,
en tant que jeune survivante d'agressions sexuelles,
faisant face à l'abandon,
et sujette à la violence dans d'autres parties de ma vie.
Je me battais contre lui,
mais aussi contre ces hommes et garçons qui m'avaient agressée,
et contre cette culture qui m'imposait de ne pas en parler.
Un enseignant nous a séparés
et la principale m'a convoquée dans son bureau.
Mais elle ne m'a pas dit : « Monique, qu'est-ce qui ne va pas chez toi ? »
Elle m'a laissée reprendre mon souffle
et m'a demandé : « Que s'est-il passé ? »
Mes éducateurs ont fait preuve d'empathie.
Ils me connaissaient.
Ils savaient que j'aimais lire, que j'aimais dessiner,
que j'adorais Prince.
Ils ont utilisé ces informations pour m'aider à comprendre
pourquoi mes actions, et celles de mes camarades
perturbaient l'aspect pédagogique de leur communauté.
Ils ne m'ont pas suspendue,
ils n'ont pas contacté la police.
Ma bagarre ne m'a pas empêchée d'aller à l'école le lendemain,
elle ne m'a pas empêchée d'obtenir mon diplôme ou d'enseigner,
Mais malheureusement, ce n'est pas la même expérience pour
beaucoup de filles noires américaines ou dans le monde.
Nous vivons une crise qui exclut
les filles noires des écoles excessivement –
pas parce que leur présence compromet la sécurité à l'école,
mais parce qu'elles associent l'école
avec des notions de sanction et de marginalisation.
C'est ce que me disent les filles noires dans tout le pays.
Mais ce n'est pas insurmontable.
Nous pouvons changer ce récit.
Commençons par quelques statistiques.
Selon une enquête de l'institut national pour la justice des femmes noires
sur les données des droits civils
recueillies par le département de l'éducation américain,
le groupe des filles noires est surreprésenté
tout au long du continuum de la discipline à l'école.
Cela ne veut pas dire que les autres filles ne se font jamais expulser
ou qu'elles ne sont pas surreprésentées
par ailleurs dans ce continuum.
Mais les filles noires sont le seul groupe
surreprésenté tout du long.
Les filles noires ont sept fois plus de chance que leurs camarades blanches
de subir au moins une suspension,
et ont près de trois fois plus de chance que les blanches ou les latinas
d'être envoyées au tribunal pour mineurs.
Une étude récente du Centre Georgetown sur la pauvreté et l'inégalité
démontre partiellement pourquoi ces disparités existent
en confirmant que les filles noires subissent
un phénomène spécifique de compression d'âge
qui les fait paraître plus matures que leurs camarades blanches.
Entre autres, l'étude a démontré que
les gens pensent que les filles noires ont moins de besoins,
nécessitent moins de protection, sont mieux informées sur le sexe,
et sont plus indépendantes que leurs camarades blanches.
L'étude a aussi constaté que
cette disparité s'établit alors que les filles n'ont que cinq ans.
Et que cette perception et cette disparité s'intensifient au fil du temps
et culminent entre les âges de 10 et 14 ans.
Ceci n'est pas sans conséquences.
Juger qu'une fille est plus âgée peut entraîner un traitement plus sévère,
une sanction immédiate quand elle commet une erreur,
une condamnation de la victime quand on lui porte atteinte.
Cela peut aussi la persuader que c'est elle qui est à tort,
plutôt que les conditions dans lesquelles elle se trouve.
Les filles noires sont souvent perçues comme trop bruyantes, trop agressives,
trop coléreuses, trop visibles.
Qualités souvent modérées dans le cas des filles qui ne sont pas noires
et qui ignorent ce qu'il se passe par ailleurs dans la vie de cette fille,
ou ses normes culturelles.
Cela n'arrive pas qu'aux États-Unis.
En Afrique du Sud à Pretoria,
les filles noires du lycée pour filles
ont été découragées de venir à l'école avec les cheveux au naturel,
sans traitement chimique.
Qu'ont fait ces filles ?
Elles ont manifesté.
Et c'était chouette de voir la majorité de la population
serrer dans ses bras ces filles qui luttaient pour leurs droits.
Mais certains les ont jugées importunes,
surtout parce qu'elles ont osé poser cette question :
« Où peut-on être noires si on ne peut pas l'être en Afrique ? »
(Rires)
(Applaudissements)
C'est une bonne question.
Partout dans le monde,
les filles noires font face à cette question.
Et partout dans le monde,
elles luttent pour être visibles, travaillent pour être libres,
et se battent pour être incluses dans le paysage de l'espoir
que la sûreté d'un environnement éducatif apporte.
Aux États-Unis, des petites filles, à peine sorties de la maternelle,
se sont fait arrêter en classe à cause d'une crise de colère.
Des collégiennes sont exclues de l'école
pour porter leurs cheveux au naturel
ou à cause de leur tenue vestimentaire.
Des lycéennes sont sujettes à la violence
des agents de police dans les écoles.
Où les filles noires peuvent être noires sans réprimande ou sanction ?
Il ne s'agit pas que de ces incidents.
Dans mon travail de recherche et d'enseignement,
j'ai eu l'opportunité de travailler avec des filles comme Stacy,
une fille que j'ai profilée dans mon livre « Pushout »,
qui lutte contre sa propre participation à la violence.
Elle surpasse les analyses neuroscientifiques et structurelles
que la science propose
pour expliquer comment une enfance défavorable influence
un comportement violent,
et elle n'hésite pas à se décrire comme une « enfant à problèmes »,
essentiellement car ces termes étaient ceux de ses éducateurs
quand ils la suspendaient régulièrement.
Seulement voilà,
la déconnexion et l'internalisation de la souffrance
s'accroissent dans l'isolement.
Donc quand les filles ont des ennuis, il ne faut pas les repousser,
il faut les rapprocher.
L'éducation est essentielle à la protection
contre le contact avec le système judiciaire.
Il nous faut alors créer des stratégies et des méthodes
qui connectent les filles à leur scolarité
plutôt que de les en détourner.
Voilà pourquoi j'aime dire que l'éducation est le travail de la liberté.
Quand les filles se sentent en sécurité, elles peuvent étudier.
Quand elles sont en danger, elles se battent,
elles protestent, elles argumentent, elles fuient, elles se figent.
Le cerveau humain est programmé pour nous protéger en cas de menace.
Et tant que l'école représentera une menace,
ou évoquera des épisodes douloureux de sa vie,
une jeune fille voudra résister.
Mais si l'école devenait un environnement apaisant,
elle se prêterait mieux à l'apprentissage.
Alors comment créer un environnement apaisant ?
Eh bien, tout d'abord, il faut immédiatement mettre fin
aux règles et méthodes qui pénalisent les filles noires
pour leur coiffure ou leur tenue.
(Applaudissements)
Concentrons-nous sur les méthodes et la substance de son apprentissage
plutôt que de surveiller son corps tout en promouvant la culture du viol,
ou de punir les enfants à cause de leurs antécédents.
C'est là que les parents et les adultes concernés peuvent participer.
Établissez un dialogue avec l'école
et encouragez-les à réévaluer leur code vestimentaire,
et d'autres règles de conduites au sein d'un projet collaboratif
entre les parents et les élèves,
afin d'éviter le préjugé et la discrimination de façon délibérée.
Mais n'oubliez pas,
certaines des méthodes les plus blessantes ne sont pas flagrantes.
Il nous faut donc persévérer et réévaluer nos propres idées préconçues
dans notre considération des filles noires pour ce qu'elles sont vraiment,
plutôt que pour ce qu'on nous a dit.
Devenez bénévole à l'école,
et créez des ateliers de discussions adaptés à toutes les cultures, les genres
avec des filles noires, latinas, et indigènes
et toutes celles qui ont subi la marginalisation à l'école,
pour leur offrir un cadre sûr
où elles peuvent assimiler leur identité et leurs expériences scolaires.
Et pour que l'école devienne un milieu apaisant,
il faut supprimer les officiers de police
et augmenter le nombre d'éducateurs dans les écoles.
(Applaudissements)
L'éducation est le travail de la liberté.
Et peu importe notre point de départ, il faut tous nous battre pour la liberté.
Le point positif est qu'il y a des écoles
très actives dans la création d'établissements
où les filles se sentent sacrées et aimées.
L'école préparatoire pour filles, à Columbus, dans l'Ohio,
en est un bon exemple.
Ils sont devenus exemplaires quand leur principal a déclaré
qu'ils n'allaient plus punir les filles pour « mauvais comportement ».
En plus de créer --
Essentiellement, ils ont créé un environnement robuste
d'alternatives aux suspensions, expulsions et arrestations.
En plus d'établir un programme de justice réparatrice,
ils ont amélioré la relation élève-enseignant
en permettant à chaque fille d'avoir accès à au moins un adulte
en cas de crise sur le campus.
Ils ont construit le long des couloirs et dans les salles de classes
des points de rassemblement pour les filles qui en auraient besoin.
Et ils ont mis en place un programme consultatif qui offre aux filles
l'opportunité de démarrer la journée avec la valorisation de l'estime de soi,
des capacités en communication et d'établissement d'objectifs.
Dans cette école,
ils tentent de faire face aux expériences négatives de l'enfance
plutôt que de les ignorer.
Ils les rapprochent d'elles, ils ne les repoussent pas.
Et par conséquent, l'absentéisme et les suspensions ont diminué,
et les filles viennent à l'école prêtes à étudier,
car elles savent que les enseignants s'intéressent à elles.
Cela compte.
Les écoles qui intègrent les arts et le sport au curriculum,
ou qui créent un programme transformateur,
tel que la justice réparatrice, la pleine conscience et la méditation,
permettent aux filles de restaurer leurs relations avec les autres,
mais aussi avec elles-mêmes.
Répondre au traumatisme vécu, complexe et historique
que nos élèves affrontent,
exige que tous ceux qui ont de l'espoir pour nos enfants et nos adolescents
développent des relations, un support pédagogique,
des ressources humaines et financières ainsi que d'autres moyens,
qui permettent aux enfants de se rétablir, pour qu'ils puissent étudier.
La sensibilité de nos écoles envers nos filles les plus vulnérables
est essentielle à la création d'une culture scolaire positive.
Remplir cette promesse doit être de la plus grande précision
lorsqu'elle est confrontée à la pauvreté et à la dépendance,
sous le choc d'avoir été victime de trafic sexuel,
ou ayant survécu à d'autres formes de violence,
quand elle fait du bruit,
ou quand elle est réservée.
Il nous faut soutenir son bien-être intellectuel,
social et émotionnel,
qu'importe si son short lui arrive au genou, à la mi-cuisse ou plus haut.
Cette tâche peut sembler difficile dans un monde
tellement enraciné dans la politique de la crainte,
d'imaginer des écoles où les filles se rétablissent et s'épanouissent,
mais il nous faut avoir le courage de poursuivre cette intention.
Si on s'engage dans cette notion que l'éducation est le travail de la liberté,
nous pouvons changer les conditions scolaires
afin qu'aucune fille, même la plus vulnérable d'entre nous,
ne soit exclue de l'école.
Ce sera alors un succès pour nous tous.
Merci.
(Applaudissements)